welcome back to on base live in your
bleach Report app I am your host Mookie
Betts and today we got uh OG Mr J Haye
himself Jason Hayward what's going on my
man how you doing I'm good bro I'm
chilling was it tough waking up this
morning for this
no I don't think so were you excited
because you know we talked about it a
couple times and uh and uh
it didn't go through earlier and now
that you're on here were you excited
about coming on I'm excited because I'm
just curious about like what mooc's
about to ask me what's going to be the
topic of discussion the anticipation you
know
um and then like how how in depth we're
gonna go and I think I'll say that
because when I saw us going to Boston
you're going back first time
um even earlier in the year just hearing
that you thought you were going to be
there your whole career yeah like just
saying like the stuff that the the
internet picked up on from the podcast
so far this year all right I wonder what
we're gonna get into this episode well
let's get into it then my brother but
before we do
won a World Series in 2016 for those for
the viewers that don't know and OG got
five gold gloves you gonna have a chance
to win another one this year too
like you balding out there dog it's
actually it's been one of my favorite
things in the world because I've gotten
to play second base okay you're my guy I
appreciate it I appreciate it
um I don't know if I'm gonna qualify for
enough Innings you don't think so I
don't I don't think so you know that
really you know that's so hard to win
yeah you know yeah plenty of yourself
um but you don't think so I don't think
I'm good enough anyway we're gonna see
we're gonna see them we're going but
either way like playing second playing
right field behind you at second knowing
that you got gold oh yeah when the ball
goes up I'm like yeah yesterday there
was a pop-up and I looked at you and you
went the opposite way of the pop-up
opposite way it's like okay I guess he
didn't want to he didn't want to catch
it but whatever I go do it it was kind
of deep yeah it was I was deep and then
but it was kind of going like towards
foul territory and I saw you look at me
I was like yeah this is one of them time
I ain't gonna say nothing move got it
yeah who got it yeah so all right so I
play a game called on base off base
you know it's the rules are
if you like it you're in you don't like
it you're out
pretty simple so if I like it I just say
on base on base and if I don't like it
off base off base got it all right all
right so first thing Usher will be a top
five Super Bowl halftime performance
are you on base or off base on that
I feel like for where we are 2023 this
generation
a lot of people gonna know these songs
they're gonna know the vibe on bass I
think I'm on base with that too
um you know at the gala
you know that was just a little mini
show for him he had us out there shaking
it yeah
that's where the Freddy came from that's
exactly I was thinking the same thing I
was like we got a whole new like extra
bass hit celebration sign all that from
the Usher Gala songs for how I don't
even know how long he performed but it
felt like we were out there for like
three hours I think it was he was
probably out there for an hour maybe and
man he we uh we shook it so yeah I think
you're on base on that I think Usher
will for sure be a top five Super Bowl
performance all right what about this
Taylor Swift Travis Kelsey's
relationship is a PR stunt
oof
man see you like this is tough for me
because I don't want to like judge them
yeah you don't want to judge I don't
want to judge him either but you know
it won't base all basic judgments more
just to kind of talk about because I
think it's neat
I agree I think it's neat I would say
this I'm on base but I'll give like
context to that let's do it I think it's
a PR storm because that's just who they
are like they've earned that in their
lives so regular relationship or not
whatever they could be enjoying it
intimate but I think it just turns into
a PR stuff because of the accolades and
the success they both have it's
inevitable in that you know and so did
you see her at the game did you watch
some of the games I saw her sitting next
to Travis's mom and then like had some
of her crew in there and then I saw them
walk out and then I also saw that they
went to a restaurant or whatever
that post game party and she took
pictures with fans paid for the
restaurant food but said everybody y'all
got to get out of here I got your food
but you got to go so we can be normal
um
dang I did not know none of that so tell
you that that's cool good for you good
for you Taylor shout out to you for
doing that right absolutely so so I
wonder how they met you know I'm a mass
drive one day like how did that all come
about because you know I gotta let the
record show Mookie's gonna ask trial
because he knows traps like monkey got
it like that he acts like he'll have it
like that but I'm like move like why are
you asking me what we're doing today you
tell me what we do
we go about it
okay all right next subject on base all
face I asked this before and you should
I didn't get an answer
you should be able to answer oh
Magic City has the best wings in Atlanta
I'm be honest
I've only been there one time yeah I've
only been one time and I I wasn't uh I
wasn't trying to get food really but I'm
also when I eat wings like this is
dramatic and Freddie will tell you but
if I'm eating wings especially in
Atlanta
but I'm getting wings at home only
at tank top or no shirt
what
cause I'm digging in bro oh okay okay
like you I'm going in and it's lemon
pepper so yeah mild sprinkle with lemon
pepper mild sprinkle with lemon pepper
messy
but I'm digging in so I don't want to be
out somewhere in the wings and like
whatever because I'm smelling like wings
the rest of the time probably for like
into the next day because I'm grabbing
why you take your shirt off though what
you don't want to get it because it's
going to be a mess I just want to eat
them and enjoy them and like not slow
down so you don't like you you can't eat
and not
drop it on your shirt I can but it's
just like bruh just in case comfortable
like kicking it you just got drawers on
too you got things I got pants on shoes
there's no shirts mess up a shirt for
don't go ahead and just enjoy the wings
but back to the to the question like I
can't say if they do so so who
who has the best wings in Atlanta
because all the Atlanta people evidently
hadn't been the United States I don't
even know where to go I mean I don't
know who got good Wings I'm sure if you
do a poll there's plenty of people in
Atlanta that will answer okay and give
you that but I I rock with uh American
Deli every time I go home and that's I
don't get no Pub from this I don't have
no kind of deals
this is your spot American Deli
okay that's it I'm gonna go to American
Deli uh I mean you might as well go get
10 for one and ten from another and I
can answer this myself I feel that
that's gonna be the only way to find out
okay all right what about this all right
last one on this Wrigley
is the most electric stadium in the MLB
and I say that because JP Crawford came
on the show and he he said to him
Wrigley was his favorite uh Park and he
referenced when you hit a walk-off Grand
Slam and he said that feeling of you
know when even though he was on the
other team like that feeling was the
most electric thing that he had been a
part of
no I got I gotta give it to him and I
got to give it to Rigby
um even before I signed with the Cubs
played there for seven years like that
was my favorite ballpark to visit all
time whether you got no VP because it's
Day games or you had night game there
was always that nostalgia
but uh
I compared playing in Wrigley to
something I haven't even seen in person
yet
um you know hopefully I get to do that
this off season but catching like a
European
um
yeah to me it's just that Vibe it's like
well it's just people are locked into
the game you're allowed to drink
obviously like and taking alcohol at
Wrigley
um but it's like it's like a day party
bro that's okay you know what I'm saying
because that's what the date the day
games and you play so many Day games so
you don't really get to you know go
through the BP and do all this stuff so
really it's just you kind of wake up in
the morning you go play and the feeling
around you is like folks are here just
kicking it kicking it bro but they're
watching the game too because Chicago
fans are are they are they own you bro
they know the game they love the game
um
it's just in it's in their DNA but it's
just it's just so many people it's
it's just a Vibe like the smallest
detail but ball won during the bad fan
you know and like the first time I
remember seeing that um in my career was
going to Boston when I was with Atlanta
because Boston was good at the time
um they won in 13 The Ring
but
you know regularly just when we were
rolling we had that four to five year
stretch right everything like you can
reface on the air Family Guy going crazy
good hustle yeah yeah you know
um but I haven't gotten experience
really like that this is so that walk
off to JP's point that was that was that
was a dope and you pimped it a little
bit you'll never do that
that was the end yeah
all right so let's uh let's keep it
moving so you know this is your first
year here
and
you instantly like kind of took on took
on a leadership role there's really like
a little group of us
but you know you're one of the main
leaders or whatever you want to call
yourself and you won the Royal
Campanella award
how to put this being your first year
here you went in the Roy campanilla
award you
taking on this quote-unquote leadership
role amongst the group like how has it
been being a leader or whatever with the
Dodgers and and being a part of all that
um I think the biggest thing like you
said like is a group of us so it's not
something that's comes along like it
doesn't you know just happen like an
instant thing like oh yeah hey came in
here OG came in and started talking and
we had a leader yeah you know like it's
it's fun to be a part of this group and
the vibe that we have that does help
lead this team
um but then to come in like year one
first time with a group it's been
special it's been different man as you
see but see that's something you can say
I think that's the biggest and most
rewarding thing for me is like to hear
from people that have been here like
that it's been different in a good way
yeah not shaming or you know talking
down
but like it's cool to see good
differences and that and that's the
thing like that's what I love about the
Dodgers as a whole like you know they
they do anything and everything for the
guys for the players and so
um you know I mean I think
adding on guys you know we lost some
guys and they got and part of that is
just the business part of it right they
gotta the Dodgers are gonna do its best
for the for the business part of it and
then
they brought in guys like human and I
think that's why uh not even base not
even baseball-wise not even playing the
game I guess guys like you and Miggy DP
and Arlo crew I think that's why we're
good and that's because we have our
little group of leaders man it's it's
it's it's it's dope it's funny it's
funny because those guys are hilarious
hilarious the bus rides all that stuff
um you know whatever so and then going
through the season you taking on this
leadership role or whatever and it
really fits you because
you've also been playing well you know
as well and you know for a little bit
you
you stopped getting a little playing
time and
how was it going through that because
you assigned the deal with with Chicago
for what was it 190 or something like
184.2 184.2 I believe okay so you signed
that deal boom boom boom and then you
get to a point where
you may not I ain't gonna say you're not
the same player but it's it's
you go through a rough patch and and
tell me about going through that rough
patch I got you no I appreciate you
asking that
um
I feel like when I came in the game yep
20 years old 2010. like but you play
every day every day don't ask any
questions and there were steps along the
way where I had veterans coaches whoever
helped show me that that's also the way
okay and that you're not always going to
feel 100 no doubt I mean you know
there's a whole type of meaning and
feeling on that
um
but then getting to Chicago
it was like all right like y'all just
saw me play in 2015 with Saint Louis
started off really slow with them new
scene new Vibe whatever
get acclimated in and played it out and
had a really good year did a lot of
things to help my team win run the bases
Gold Glove defense all that and so I'm
seeing myself get to Chicago and I'm
like okay we got a really good team
there's High expectation once again
starting off slow
and
I'm just like all right well I'm just
gonna keep playing and I'm gonna figure
this out gonna get through it a little
knickknack injury this now whatever
that's forget it like so let's go play
let's win and
that first year 2016 was probably like
one of the toughest years personally in
my life like on the field off the field
but because we're playing baseball and
I'm playing at Wrigley
got a great team around me bro let's go
win and enjoy that it was almost like a
getaway for you
probably I would assume it felt like
there was no getaway oh not even not
even at that time
okay so that's rough tell me some more
bro it's just you know living life like
that was the third New City
second new city in three years yep going
from Atlanta Home St Louis then Chicago
um they came by like that was different
you know that's a whole different like I
I'll now we'll talk about that later
yeah yeah that Deuce all day games is
like completely different too figuring
that out but also not doing it with some
more expectation but also just like more
attention put on are you trying to hire
Contracting
eyes are on you especially in Chicago
you know what do we what do we just pay
for let's see it exactly absolutely but
that's fine like I'm not about baseball
you're gonna fail right and doing it my
whole life like
how do you handle it and I think that's
just that was the epitome of that first
year
um how do you handle it and it was
helping my team bring home a
championship but
each year I feel like I progressed got
better figured it out figured out the
system the matchups but the toughest
thing was the two parts
they weren't really sure how they wanted
to do it matchup wise and like for our
whole team and stuff because we had a
bunch of first rounders on that group oh
yeah you know like you've been for a
long time you got a bunch of first
rounds to come up and do well contribute
so we were all like hold on
that's not how you came up no so I'm
like bro everybody looking at me like
this man ducking out on us you know I'm
like brother I want to play but I'm not
playing it right they're like okay you
hit a grand slam man you out huh you're
gonna leave us so those are thoughts
that are kind of get in the way of like
what's important right focusing on swing
Rhythm flow all that kind of stuff
um then it got to a point in 2019 I shot
off really well had it had a nice April
um we had just got back from Seattle
actually I think I'm hitting 328 330 at
the time and we're gonna face St Louis
three ridies okay starting
first game I think I started batted
eighth in front of the picture okay and
then
the next game I don't start
walkers on the mountain and I'm like
bro what we got going here like we
trying to stay in first place like I
think we were out of first by two games
or maybe in first by a couple whatever
it was but I'm like bro
this this never adds up to me like I get
it if I'm not playing well but if I'm
playing well
get in there
um but those are things that I just had
to learn how to deal with on the fly in
this new era of baseball yeah
and I think that was a part of the tough
times in Chicago just way too many
thoughts
not focused on what do I need every day
to be this person myself
um but learn how to do that like you had
to learn how to do that on the Fly and
you can't there's no way to learn the
the only experience and once you
experience it's too late you can't go
back and change it right you know 100
and and so that was to me like the
difficult time there but
um I ended up in that game actually
someone got hurt coming off the bench so
I had a face Walker almost hit a homer
one time flew out deep left Center good
swipe and then I don't remember what
happened next to that maybe I got out
maybe I won't Whatever whatever it
didn't matter but either way just things
like that I'm just like bro there's a
lot of stuff not making sense here that
I'm trying to get wrap my head around
but I need to be focused on playing yeah
but you you let it affect you in the
wrong way absolutely that's cool though
I mean that's that's part of it that's
part of the so let's go back before that
because if I want to talk to you when
you you're from Georgia and then you got
it drafted by Atlanta and getting
drafted by your hometown team
you know like how was that like you know
I'm assuming all your homeboys everybody
that everybody's excited about it
absolutely take me through that Draft
Day draft day was I believe it when I
see it like that was my whole um okay
everybody said oh you gonna get right to
here top top five top top four whatever
the uh Rocky's gonna take you with the
eighth pick
oh if they don't want you the Marlins
really want you at 12 like what what you
think
and then it's like okay well Atlanta's
at 14. you know hopefully that works out
I'm like yeah that would be that would
be cool but you didn't care where you
went though I wanted to go as high as I
can go okay just based on like the work
put in my family uh mom and pop
sacrifices everyone coaches all that
stuff trainers I'm like bro we're
shooting for the top and then we'll see
where it falls David Price go to one
overall rightfully so cold dude
um but I ended up getting drafted by
Atlanta and that was the first year did
the first round of draft was on
television okay okay but I stayed at
home with the fam whatever people around
me
get down to the 14th pick
people like oh this is it this is it I'm
like yeah we'll see
and the phone rings
it's the Braves calling everybody's you
know doing the whole listening in and
stuff um
and then they let me know hey we would
love you being Atlanta Brave and this
and that would love to have you and your
family come down to the stadium a day if
you can
um I hang up the phone and they're like
is that it that was it that was it that
was it and and so that was that was
really cool that was cool man I bet that
was cool especially going because I feel
like you know growing up in Nashville my
man you know it'll be so cool to stay
and play in Nashville but then now now
that I'm playing
I don't know that I would enjoy playing
you know I feel like home was it would
be a lot worse but whatever it is it is
what it is and you hoped before I mean I
ain't gonna say before you started
playing baseball but
I hope like hoop-ish like yeah you're
left-handed you you ain't have a jumper
I could shoot I could play I could I
would compare my game to James Harden
but I just gotta I can't disrespect the
crap because I know how hard it is to to
be good at something yep I was playing
with the dudes in in PE they were on the
team and whatnot every time the
basketball coach from my high school
came in the gym he was looking at them
oh he got mad at you
I don't know what you're doing like he
got me out here looking like a fool for
not playing this and that he didn't hit
dunking catching oops shooting three
whatever but I don't know how good I
would have been if I played for real for
real I would have worked at it and then
and competed but like I had a lot of fun
in my high school Heyday and do you
still talk to like your homeboys from
pooping bro no I don't I didn't move
Oh I thought you you didn't play you
didn't play no high school not even
early or nothing I played baseball only
so you just didn't want to play so it
came down to
basketball starts in the fall right
pretty much like practices and then the
real tournament for high school was like
all right kicks off like Christmas
holiday time
perfect game when I was 14 years old
that was like the big time to get to the
underclass Showcase my Powers was like
all right well you can play basketball
that's cool he played basketball his
uncle played basketball you said late
for John Wooden oh nice okay
but he was like you can play basketball
but you ain't doing baseball too at the
same time we ain't doing the Showcase
and it's not and you like which one are
you gonna pick I was like we're going to
do yeah that's what you want to do down
here and get this exposure and so that's
how it just ended up being um
baseball only for me because showcases
took over and there was no off season
so to speak no I mean especially in
Georgia because Georgia's you know guys
are playing the whole year had had to
had two at that time and that was kind
of like the kickoff of like starting to
be more travel ball ahead oh okay um but
you know my friends and stuff like that
from high school
never forget them
um
but we went through everything so you
that's crazy man
I didn't I thought for sure you would
have hoped or did something else other
than base because you're too athletic
you know what I'm saying you're too
athletic to to just but I mean I guess
it and what's crazy for me like I did
the opposite I probably hope more than I
played baseball so if I had to play
baseball I could have maybe went earlier
um maybe went early in the day
I don't know a couple maybe three oh no
no we're gonna see we're gonna try to
put it and then okay so
uh playing ball get drafted all stuff
you go to the minor leagues and you flew
through because you debuted so early
take me through your first at bat so
your first step back
you are on Deck tell me about from on
Deck to that about because it was epic
before I get to on Deck
this is before the game I'm in my locker
your rookie 20 years old but you are
singing and not hurt
um okay okay and um but I'm just kind of
locking in like to what I think is
locking in for a game at that time yep
because you don't really know what lock
and that means right but yeah okay
everything's new yeah at this point it's
not new baseball but it's new
chip comes over to me
oh damn what I do well I do I was like
I'm in the wrong spot where I need to be
and he's like hey
same game
60 feet six inches 90 feet in the base
pass same game
you know play a ball do you think all
right
now now let's get back on that okay we
go down three nothing yep
in the top of the first
I'm batting seventh on on this day and
by the time I'm going to hit it's 3-3 we
tied up
two guys on base chip is one of the two
guys that score on the play before me
I'm like you know same game this and
that I see chip just [__] look
at me talk about something hey let's go
big boys
let's go
but I still I did a pretty good job of
just being in the moment slowing things
down
um
taking some deep breaths whatever I had
to do getting into this at bat and just
want to keep it simple like don't try
and do too much
um first couple pitches Zambrano up in
here and letting it eat oh I know that
was coming in hot too coming in hot man
Angry you know especially it's not like
98. yeah especially after giving up you
know
three in well I guess I ended up giving
what giving up how many uh what he gave
up three at that point at that point
yeah after they took the league yeah
yeah
um
but first couple pitches not brush back
but he was hoping like I swing in off
whatever and you were a rookie so he's
probably trying to take it out on
YouTube
so next page 2-0 so all right bro like
be ready like we hung
Ry I need you swipe
didn't even feel it hit the bad Ah
that's the best feeling in the world you
know like back of the bullpen
and I hit the ball I'm like bro that's
that's leaving but I'm like it went that
far you know
um hit the bait touch the bases my
helmet I remember my ear hole just
vibrating like rattling is around the
base because it was so loud
and
I heard the chance of let's go hey we're
this and that but um I just think
everybody was just tuning in to let's
see what happens here let's do it from
here whatever
um Cubs Braves and let's just see how it
goes in first Wing Homer but as I get
between first and second the only
thought of my mind was but we went down
three
that's that's all I cared about and
let's go that's kind of that's probably
what has and what will keep you around
for a long time and something I had to
learn is
your first thought was we're winning
like just simply winning the game like
playing to win I feel like makes you a
better player
it doesn't take
it does take practice and all this stuff
right but
playing the game not for yourself but
playing it to win
I feel like makes it uh
makes you feel a little bit better even
if you don't play well and
people like being around you you know
what I'm saying people like being around
you people like
you know just you you're you when you
play to win
you look like Jason Hayward damn maybe
not physically that's coming from
because that's uh he's a he's a physical
specimen under clothes you know you look
great I wish I could be long and swole
like that but it is what it is so hey
you work at it every day I see that yeah
all right so go back let's go back to 16
because you know
you want y'all won the World Series that
you're in Chicago I think there was a
rain delay and you had a speech or a
talk
and I don't know if people know about
that
can you tell us about it or or was that
kind of like behind closed doors oh I
can I can speak on it I want to hear
about that because I don't even know
about it
I know Cubs fans know about it because
they were just every little detail
they hold on to which is which is
amazing
um
but
that was just like right time right
place right people
um
it was the
it was top nine we're headed to bottom
nine okay
tied and
you know they had just tied the game we
had been up all game this is game seven
of course
um coming back down from 3-1
to Cleveland some some badass dudes dude
they they I mean I remember man
they was cold like pictures
yeah two catchers they could call a game
yeah they swept us there yeah you know
going in so keep going yeah and
so in my head when they tied the game
LeBron going crazy on the jumbo
challenge that was the Chapman uh rajay
Davis yeah bro Roger is choked up on the
bat like yeah if it's the
up here
like this like we had at least four or
five inches I'm gonna hit 98 I ain't
gonna miss it and he hit it he hit it
but in all fairness the champion like
bro chappie threw 55 pitches in game
five at Wrigley the only game we won at
Wrigley that year
so he I think he threw he came in in the
seven yeah yeah
I was on base watching the road to
Chapman saying in the box like we're in
the World Series
okay game six we win we're up five or
six he comes in the game again in game
six
and then we get to a game seven
and okay bro like they've seen him for
three games yes three four games
55 pictures of it he's running on fumes
at this point
but it's also to every the four seam
slider change in the time at the time
today he's kind of modified that and
that's how he's lasted but bro he was he
was spent
and so for Raji to be able to connect on
98 which was not his best fastball no
that was 98 hearing that at the time
that's like slow right for him yeah
like obviously it was a big moment for
them
but in my head when it happened I'm just
like all right bro like that's dope
Rogers like you're the Homer LeBron
going crazy the fans Cleveland cool we
should buy to win the game though
come right back and so the next inning
top nine somebody gets on base
I hit a hard ground or whatever but
Force out I get the first base but I
still second they throw it away I get
the third base one down I'm over there
talking about somebody
like hey that's a movie by the way if
anybody I know baseball movie one of the
best all-time yeah
um one of my favorites for sure but
that's all I'm thinking about him like
bro anyway you can get home and touch
that plate and score
do it but hops up and
Hobbies already gone deep this game NLCS
co-nvp for us him and Johnny Lester
mm-hmm
hits a homer off kluber cutter bomb like
right center I believe center right
center
it's Shaw righty Shaw who does Cutters
yeah he's got a slider guy I'm like bro
how I'm gonna go deep again he wears the
three two other bro this at least Sac
fly and
Jonesy third base coach at the time
who's with Detroit now the third base
coach comes with me like hey
Skipper once you shake the squeak
I said clearly but I had to say how he
said he said hey Skipper wants a safety
squeeze
he goes and talks to hop hops like hey
don't you like you know I got two
strings bro
he's like yeah I know one shape to
squeak uh okay come tell me I'm like
so safety squeeze for people who don't
know you're on third base sometimes it
happens a lot of times it happens with a
run on first as well there's nobody on
first it's just me on third
you get down the line you anticipate a
bunch going down and when it's down you
have to read and decipher
if it's a good player run on or not
hard it's a very hard play to it's not
really done anymore right you gotta
gamble but you gotta gamble right
and all that going on in my head I can
only imagine what's going on at Hobbs
head he tries to burn it it's a cutter
you're out
and I just felt like our whole team was
like bro what what is going on
like what's up but not only our team
then you got the 30 000 Cubs fans over
there that night for game seven and then
anybody else watching I can't imagine
being somewhere else in here like oh I
remember watching bro on the radio and I
seen that
you know obviously I can't say it now
but it's like you know what are you
doing no I cannot I can't say it on air
though I was going crazy I was cussing
bro cussing yeah yeah cussing y'all out
like in our head and openly like bro
what the [__] was that yeah like this is
hard yeah because we're believing each
other that much you know but I know that
for Joe
it's my one to win
bad he'd been there before on The
Winning Side as a only members of the
bench coach but he was on the staff with
the angels when they won in O2 yep of
course with Tampa no eight you know came
so close against Philly they had a tough
team but he was willing to think outside
the box and do whatever it took
to get an advantage and that's what made
him to me the perfect guy to lead that
group to break in church 108 years
um but that was just a little we were
going for that's coming up I'm still
like all right Jay like you know we we
can still do this you know it's two
hours right it ain't the same as one
hour but no that's that that's you go we
go and Dexter's Dex is balling
especially throughout the postseason
played the game off with a home yep
All-Star yep you know and I'm like yeah
that's that's gonna get it done
hits a ball hard one hopper at the
middle this was before they cared about
shifts and what side you're on
my oh that's through there man Lindo
come across the middle stand that don't
like this throw it over the first day
run on the field I'm like bro we ain't
score
and I come back in the Dugout everybody
else just like sunk
oh like
what was that yeah didn't score stuff
starting to snowball
started raining and I was like
a little couple heavy cold drops but
we're probably gonna keep playing now
they've started coming down hey they
pulling it
I was like oh snap I said I got I gotta
say something
I just gotta say something wrong you
just felt it it just hit just hit me I'm
like I gotta say something to them like
we came too far
too good like put too much into it
this ain't who we are right now I don't
like this feeling and my roster hey bro
just today Ross bro tell people like
real quick man it's just me in the
weight room like so the man the coaches
were in there too no just the players
just the players so when we get in there
our strength coach Tim bus
Legend in Chicago Legend with the Cubs
Legend in baseball
um
he was about to walk out he's like man
let me get the [__] out of here guys way
like all that busy get your ass in the
[__] Corner bro like if anybody needs
to be in here you yeah
oh okay I'm like yeah absolutely but
chappie was wearing it pretty heavy like
Angry Tears like bro I just let the team
down but also kind of felt defeated in a
sense of like bro I was just given a
really tough task I wanted it but they
got me that time I thought bro you do it
don't even don't even worry about it but
we we got you and then other people
timed in on that as well rizz decks
judge Ford Zoe swarp um
but I was like look like we want 130
regular season games
we've been doing our thing in the
postseason overcoming all type of
adversity with clinched and San Fran
down from 2-1 against la
and here we are like we've handled
I want to say [__] but like the
unexpected all of it yeah you know all
year long better than anyone that's why
we're here right now back from 3-1
I was like bro like let's go we can't
control that stuff like every team has
that right stuff they deal with all year
I was like let's let's finish this thing
how we start
as us like that's it like I don't know
what's gonna happen I don't know what
the result is going to be but so many
times that season it just felt like bro
we did not care if we won the game or
not
um but like we will be really well
somebody on defense all of us we were so
in sync like if somebody made an error
kind of like our team right now 2023
but even more showed in like bro
somebody was talking [__] oh really
somebody made everybody look at this bro
like what you doing bro like you over
here throwing [__] away like yeah okay
let's go yeah the real should be like
hey man hit me in the [__] chest
let's go man yeah yeah like if Wilson
threw a ball like too hard or radically
or whatever it is like hold on bro like
let's go yeah okay work on that so
I'm like I just need to see that I need
to see those vibes let's let's finish
that way yeah and then well the right
people in the room people started
chiming in and yeah you just need to
start it off that's it just just get the
morale back to not give anything and
obviously it worked it won the ring
right what did you do after you won the
ring did you did you go to Disneyland or
something
I did not deserve to go to no [__]
business what did you do I um
I went to the Gold Glove ceremony in New
York
you didn't celebrate you ain't going
nowhere to celebrate I mean obviously
with the team I like for you personally
like did y'all like you know we I want
or buy yourself a chain or whatever it
is you know nothing
I was um
I was given gifted a private flight from
the Gold Glove event
um from New York to Arizona where
out of the moment spread a moment that's
where I was spending my off season
in the complex in Mesa and I went
outside and I ran some Sprints um
I walked in people like yo Jay what's up
back The champ is here I don't know if
we start some music what I was like bro
y'all get the [__] out of my way I'm
going to field four back here and I got
some poets run
because uh that ain't it yeah okay
um
went on a vacation you know after that
for for a couple weeks but then it was
right back to Mesa
bro I had just built a home in Atlanta
end of 2015 it was completed
when I got done with the season with St
Louis
and 2015 is the last like off-season I
lived in Atlanta the last offices I
lived in that house
I immediately said I'm going to Arizona
I got work to do need to get everything
done at one time spent the next couple
off Seasons out there
um then it was back and forth between
there and Chicago okay so and then you
you know in Chicago boom and then this
take me to this off season because I
know you and Freddie because all the my
during all this time Freddie's around
like you and Freddie are the original
homeboys
and
you know I've gotten gotten really tight
with Freddie so you we both understand
Freddy obviously you do a different way
since you've known him since you were
18. y'all played minor league ball
together 16. there you go so I might
only bought everything together and so
now
I'm going through this off season I know
he played a part in getting you here so
how what kind of role or what what did
he tell you about the Dodgers that made
you
want to uh come over to quote unquote
the dark side
um
he he didn't have to sell me much
um outside looking in as a baseball
player a competitor
I already knew what it was like expect
to win right and the attitude starts
from the top yep
um roster construction amount of money
put into it but also the amount of time
put into bringing Personnel in someone
like myself
um you know as an opportunity to let's
get the best out of this guy I've seen
that over and over over the years
um the a big one that stands out to me
is Justin Turner when he came over from
the match he got to LA
it's probably just that's where he
became Justin Turner right Mr JT for me
when he had to walk out Justin
Timberlake I was like bro that was that
was dope that was dope that's dope I
remember hearing it but all in all like
I had already had kind of my own
understanding
and Beggars can't be choosed at this
point I'm like bro somebody may not call
I might be going to the house and hang
out with the fam and figuring something
else out okay
um but free small pitch was hey you you
were really like mookie
um he's a gamer dude loves to loves to
win
goes about it right away every day
curse is awesome this and that Andrew
and them like they put a lot of time
into to trying to win every single day
um Doc's really great communicator
um the kind of those things that I
remember at the time
but he was like look man like they'll
shoot you straight I think that was
probably the biggest thing was they
would shoot you straight they'll tell
you everything they're thinking and
you'll always know where you're standing
with them and I told Andrew that's
that's the best they can do to you and
do right by you in that way and it's
been that and and more sense what do you
and then obviously like I said earlier
you're having a really good year
and do you
you've had hitting coaches
many hitting coaches I'm sure I've had
many hitting coaches
where would you rank like our our guys
the the group
collectively top
yeah I would say that it's not even just
the two the main two guys
because it's it's a whole it like you
said it's a whole group of people and it
really Emily who is in there with us
she's like really
one of the most important people I've
ever met Guru yes she's a guru when it
comes to hitting and it's like
you wouldn't know that right you know
and to your point like you have you
think you only have one or two hitting
coaches now you really got a group of
them right and so you feel like that has
really
um helped you a lot I'm assuming I
believe so and would you say that
I'm not gonna say everybody
should have access to this type of
things but would you say that
everybody should kind of if you want to
become better if you want to get better
you should kind of learn about some of
these things I know obviously access is
one thing but some of the things that
you're learning like I feel like
everyone should
get access to or at least try and like
the Driveline type stuff you know I'm
saying like I feel like everyone has
access to it if you want to become a
better player
you need to do things like Driveline on
the mocap or learn about these type of
things and so I feel like the Dodgers do
a really really good job of that and
seeing you
seeing it it's like seeing you is like a
a live test you know what I'm saying I I
I've only had my own experience with it
but seeing you it's like man
you know it it's super cool being being
a doctor like I now I'm just saying this
now like being a Dodger and I'm blessed
you know to have access to these type of
things and these people no doubt you
know and especially you now but you know
the hitting coaches and the the Clayton
even Clayton are are our Outfield first
base coach like
awesome that's why things like really
imperative is that bro literally
everyone is on the same page you know
um and when I say that not just for like
the message like that's that's already
like an accomplishment in itself like
everyone be on the same page like hey
your hips this and that whatever it is
or just stick it whatever it is or you
finish or you're starting any of that
stuff but then to have everyone be on
the same page like in the tough times
right like they're here people know what
you're grinding with
and for them to be there and it's kind
of like
checks and balances accountability they
do all that consoling like just bro your
positioning how you're standing posture
whatever
like you can intend to do all those
things but
they have it down to me as the most
organic
way for it to be done and it's really
genuine it is it is super genuine they
care about you their therapy like you
said the therapist I mean everything is
so uh like I said it's I'm glad you're a
Dodge I'm glad that you're happy to be a
Dodger and that you
um
have resurged because it's super dope
man it's super and Freddie Freddie told
me like we got to get Jason here man
you're gonna love him and and I was like
I ain't never really because I we had
never really met ever ever yeah you know
what I'm saying and so
I mean we wrote outfit when you're both
outfielders like you never cross paths
especially American League national
league so you know I had never been to
Wrigley I think I had played you know
one time I played against y'all maybe
once or twice and so we had never
crossed paths and he was telling me
you're gonna love Jason You're Gonna
Love Jason
we'll see and and it turns out you know
what I'm saying now it's like with the
Three Amigos
um you know
the Oreo
I appreciate you bro I appreciate you of
course of course bro so
um yesterday we played uh well I was
with JD
you like football right
I appreciate the off-season football
like you got something to watch every
Monday Thursday Sunday and you got some
camaraderie with friends family whatever
like get to watch Gladiators do that
thing
and you're in our Fantasy League
I'm in there
I'm in there as well me and JD are on
teams and
playing fantasy
um
I'm not good at it you know I'm not good
at it I've uh I'm in the league but now
I don't really watch what's going on
it's hard it's too hard for me to keep
up with it's very hard you know it I
feel like on Thursday night when you got
to do your lineup
I'm bowling man I ain't got time to be
but whatever fantasy you know whatever
it is you're doing yeah you know what
I'm saying like I'm saying like I'm not
locked into setting the lineup or I
can't do that who's a match up the TR
who traded somebody to waiver wire all
type of stuff we got guys that are all
in on it you know locked in they want to
talk about trades during the game after
the game before the game and I get it
that's their cup of tea I'm the people I
know is on my teams I got two of them
and Tyreek Hill after that I don't know
who we got so who's on your team so I'm
I'm a part of the group The Tres Amigos
all right so who's who is Brandon who's
like our President of Operations okay
and no Brandon uh Clover Brandon
clubhouse oh little Brandon running it
oh and then Mickey Rowe okay so we like
the assistant GM's but I'm I'm really
like the assistant to the assistant all
right so you down on the total road down
on the totem pole but seeing that
dialogue between Mickey and Brandon
every day bro when they have our little
group chat [__] like Brandon what do
you mean that you don't know how it's
going to go this week
he doesn't really know anything about
football he knows bro oh Mickey though
Mickey knows he acts like he doesn't
right he act like he don't me I don't I
know nothing about football I know
nothing about football he's being
respectful to like he don't know the X's
and O's uh he knows the players okay he
knows matchups and stuff like that so
that dialogue is hilarious but we got um
Jalen hurts
Travis Kelsey okay
um on our bench at the moment as a
backup to be because Jalen runs the ball
a lot whatever you don't know how it's
going to go we got birdie from uh San
Francisco b-e-r-t-i no that's that's the
that's the he plays it I think that's
his name birdie though right the 49ers
I don't know I'm going to clubhouse but
you don't know who's on your bench right
now you know that that's exactly how
they would look at that that's exactly
especially like bro he was like trading
with me trading to me right now but nah
like I can't keep up with it you know
okay all right so at least I don't feel
bad so okay
let's do this because I played this game
with with JD yesterday we're gonna make
our own fantasy team and this is with
Dodger players
so we're picking like our lineup
football
we're going football okay so I I you
follow me I got you so I played this
with JD and I'm not gonna make the same
team yesterday make a different team but
one thing I will say
is for my QB
my qb1 from my fantasy team
after that I'll change everybody else so
who's your qb1 on our Dodgers roster
I would say you but you are the people
okay so you gotta pick somebody up
um
I'm gonna go with Bobby Bobby Miller
Bobby Miller okay I bet you're gonna go
with like curse or somebody like that
I will go with curse but
you went with Bobby I want Bobby because
I'm just like I'm thinking like the Deep
ball Bobby probably got a bazooka
because I'm I'm white out one okay so
before we get there before we get there
okay who are you going with your D end I
I I went greater all yesterday
right that's right that's cool I think
today
for my D end
I'm gonna go with
[Applause]
I think I want to go with we don't have
that many options for this not for the
end not any
[Music]
big athletic dudes I mean ground is a
perfect one DN now I mean
howdy I'm gonna go outman
I was thinking that
who you got
I'm just gonna go grab her all that you
guys okay all right cool
okay so we know who while receiver one
is you pick you I picked Joe Kelly
yesterday okay
so now
I'm trying to think who I'm gonna pick
today my wide receiver won
to uh
I think I may go with
a sleeper who I feel like is really
athletic and CT
I like that I like that a lot because
he's fast yeah
and he's like really coordinated you
know what I'm saying like yeah you know
because there's a lot of guys that are
really fast and can't run and catch
right CT is not one of those he can do
awesome he's a baller ball player baller
Juggernaut all right so what about your
running back
hold on I gotta go running back right
now yeah you picking it I can't you want
me to go first no I'm saying can I go
something else before you claim it yeah
be competing okay go ahead tight end
Freddie free okay boom Titan Freddie
free boom okay your tight end is Freddy
free I that's that's there is I don't
know that there's a better option for
that on our team let's go but let me see
Freddie freeze your tight end I will go
with
you know what I think I would go months
because he played football
and I bet he's really good at football
yeah and he's coordinated like he ain't
fast but he got cash you know he could
catch move around he likes physicality
and he's gonna trust somebody and he
gonna run over somebody yeah I had him
as my fullback yesterday okay but uh
tight end today so okay so now now
running back who who you guys your
running back
running back you already took Audi that
was gonna be my running back yeah but
you can you can have money for your
money I can't we can do that yeah
whatever it's a fantastic it's fantasy I
mean let me see if I another option then
all right first but so
um I think I picked Audi yesterday you
know who I made would pick today as my
running back
I think I would do
um
and I I was going to say Peralta but no
he don't breathe with it nah he did not
breathe when he run and he he he'd be
running on his toes but for about to go
go through the hole again
you put on his back boy right here
I don't know who I don't know who my
running back would be
Kylie
um
you know what no
you know what I think I may go with like
pepio
pep because I feel like pep is he's the
perfect balance of
confident to go in and do it but I think
he has the the little insecurity of not
pitching well or not hitting the hole or
whatever it's gonna make him do it you
know what I'm saying yeah he's he's
scared to not do it so he's gonna do it
who's your guy
oh
I'm gonna go with uh Rosario Rosie Rosie
is he gonna be one of them I can hit him
in the flat yeah whatever maybe over the
middle yeah but also giving the ball and
giving him something
he's taking off okay so now last one
kicker
I said somebody Spanish yesterday it was
it was probably a microaggression
what
um because Spanish people are typically
good at soccer and I figured they could
kick
something who's who's man who's here
Mickey road but I wouldn't trust him as
the kicker uh
no uh if I knew he had to kick if it was
Biggie and I had three seconds left on
the clock and Mickey had the lineup for
a kick I think he would be laughing and
joking no matter what no matter what
there is no locking with me but I
wouldn't pick him I wouldn't pick him DP
uh
I don't know who I would pick for my
Kicker man because I haven't seen
anybody really kick a ball but I'm gonna
pick
um
I'm gonna pick
EP Adam Phillips because he's the closer
he's the closer
he's been in the spot
he's going to get more chances to do it
during the game
my clothes I think I'm just gonna go for
two because
we don't have any kick it out you qb1 so
you might yeah
I feel like I trust myself to do it to
to get us in there monkey [__] you ever
done Immaculate grid we'll have to do it
don't even worry about it
um I'm not good at it and I remember uh
I I don't really want to do myself like
that today you know what I'm saying
because we're gonna get up there I mean
unless you want to do it you want to do
it I've never done this yeah you know
what I'm saying I tried though a Hall of
Fame Brave who's a Hall of Fame Brave
Hall of Fame I mean Greg Maddox
so that's your pick uh he's in the Hall
of Fame right yeah I understand that
yeah let's roll Greg Maddox
so do I go with another one now or oh we
could do that we just filled out the
whole thing okay uh uh so
Cleveland is Jim told me
Jim told me
Hall of Fame let's go with Jim told me
uh Kansas City Hall of George Brett I
mean
I think Georgia bread right
Atlanta All-Star
I mean Atlanta
Hank Aaron there you go I got I gotta
have your name in there all right
a Cleveland All-Star I mean there's
a million of them
um let's go uh Kenny lofty okay I don't
know if he was an All-Star I don't know
about to find out there it ain't gonna
be my fault
that far
got him all right uh Kansas City
All-Star
um we're going Bo Jackson
you're crushing it bro
hello all right so now you got three
more uh a brave that's won 20 games
I mean there's like a boy
there's a million of them so I'm glad
there you go
time collab
all right a uh uh a guardian Cleveland
that has a 120 game tonight I don't know
this is about it oh see see that oh nice
okay all right cool add two come on
CC too cold
no he never won 20 games
okay okay okay
what about uh
the last one like another one are we are
we going we only got one more guess okay
so uh or you could do the the uh
Cleveland 20 win or Kansas City 21 which
one you want to do
I'm gonna go
Cleveland
20 wins yeah Cleveland
um I don't even know all the pictures
quickly I don't know there's two I could
guess dang okay give me an options it's
either kluber or um Bartolo
I think I want to go I don't
yeah man when he was with Cleveland
black guy didn't he get us do you decide
on with him I think I'm saying kluber
let's do a clover then let's try kluber
come on get in there
all right
did we get it yep let's go what was the
last one on the bottom right because I
don't know before we
yeah let's see who's on the bottom right
I want to see what that five chances I
don't know
I ain't never oh who was that
I don't know Brett saberhagen I don't
know I remember the name you remember
the name I remember the name
sorry Brett I don't mean disrespect you
no no doubt all right so you know what
we got a couple fan questions you want
to answer a couple questions let's do it
all right let's do it how did you choose
the wine when you gifted the Dodgers I
know early you you gave us a bottle of
wine so how did you go about choosing
the wine
um I just
chose something that positive vibes and
it made me feel like cozy in a happy
space when I think about Caymans I think
about like off season
um
with my in-laws with these family we
have like some charcuterie type meat
fruit whatever that's just to like like
enjoy kicking it out set the mood and
get ready to carve out some space for
the real food for the real man
charcuterie hey it's European yeah all
right okay so
um which city do you like which city do
you love more St Louis or Chicago
St Louis or Chicago to Chicago Chicago
I'm a resident I know for you yeah I
know yeah a bad I mean it was a fan
question no I'm not understand you know
what I'm saying they they uh I know you
love Chicago just I learned it this year
when we went and just seeing we went to
your spot
um seeing you talk about just the city
in general the food the places to go
being uh being out on the water
so uh yeah I could answer that one
Chicago for sure all right last one
um and this is a easy answer who's the
most locked into the the fantasy league
the most locked in
I don't think there's only one man yeah
I mean he's it's before the game after
the game during the game I mean I could
test him right now and ask him something
about fantasy and he would get back to
me right away I think he would if you
asked him what you were doing he
wouldn't text back whether you asked him
about fantasy right away immediately
Yeah Austin Barnes Austin Barnes awesome
without it without a doubt so oh gee
thanks for coming on the show man
um
you know it's really good you know this
season has been really good to to get to
know you
um because it's been you know we had
like I said we missed each other and you
came up a little bit before me but there
were some there's been a lot of years
that we crossed paths but never crossed
paths that makes sense you know what I'm
saying so like I said it's really uh
really good to really meet you Freddie
was right you know uh
but uh that's pretty though but yeah man
um it's been awesome I think uh you you
know
you're gonna be a super super important
piece for us not even just baseball-wise
or on the field but like off the field
for us especially going down this
stretch
um because you know me and Freddie we
get lost in playing every day you know
what I'm saying and so we need someone
to kind of keep us in check and keep us
um
yeah what word am I looking for uh hold
us accountable okay I kind of keep this
accountable and uh you do that man you
do that you Mickey Road y'all really you
you especially though you really really
do that and so I thank you for that man
because it's really helped me this year
and you've taught me how to be a better
leader
um I don't have to do it right now
because you're you're here so I just
unless you do your thing but you really
have uh have taught me a lot
um just by being around man and uh you
can always learn from someone especially
when you're open-minded you taught me to
be open-minded and just to think
differently about things and
um get you can give me a lot of
perspectives and it's just been uh
you've been nothing but positive for me
and the Dodgers bro so I want you to
know that and I'm sure everybody's
already told you that and you already
know that now you know you know you that
that dude so I appreciate y'all man but
yeah man uh thanks for coming on and uh
shoot we'll uh we'll get back on it we
got two more bro to finish strong and uh
we'll get this week we'll get this week
off so I'm so happy for the next week
man but that's besides the point anyways
thank you guys for watching it's your
boy Jay hey and uh we'll see you guys
later on thank you guys appreciate you
bro
foreign
[Music]